lorsque j'étais jeune conseiller
communal
je fréquentais tous les matins c'est au
lieu de la sociabilité valaisanne c'est
une université populaire pour
politiciens débutants qu'est le bistrot
j'y prenais mon café est assez souvent
un ami architecte féru d'art férus de
culture japonaise mais rejoignent et de
temps en temps mon ami était nettement
irrité
parfois c'était pour des raisons
personnelles sur lequel je ne m'étendrai
pas d'autres fois c'était parce que il
est extrêmement mécontents soit d'un
collaborateur soit d'un artisan qui
avait pas bien travaillé qui avait
commis des erreurs et il me disait il
faut établir en suisse
l'esprit du samouraï qui se suicide
plutôt que de mal faire ou se suicident
parce qu'il a mal fait qu'ils vont
évidemment à l'époque où on faisait
venir des ouvriers étrangers pour
travailler sur les chantiers
si on l'aurait vu les invite à se
suicider chaque fois qu'il y a
difficulté les toits il ya un problème
pratique non mais enfin nous sommes dans
une société décadente dans laquelle
chacun tolère les fautes des autres et à
la fin on va vers une société qui ne
sera plus capable de faire du travail de
qualité
l'esprit du samouraï doit être implantée
à martigny en valais ailleurs que
souhaiter bonne chance mais j'ai quand
même réfléchir assez souvent en me
demandant s'il n'y avait pas quelque
chose de vrai dans s'il est globalement
l'esprit du samouraï
c'est l'esprit de celui qui dès le
départ a la volonté de réussir et
atteindre la perfection dans son ouvrage
qui considère que la moindre faiblesse
est telle qu'il est déshonoré ça peut
aller jusqu'au suicide mais enfin c'est
en tous les cas une perte de
considération de soi même et une perte
de considération de ce qu'ils
connaissent cet artisan ou 7 personnes
alors c'est vrai que nous
autres sociétés occidentales est une
société peut pas dire du pardon mais en
tous les cas une société dans laquelle
au flou au cours des siècles s'est
développé l'idée que l'erreur comme le
disait tout à l'heure une phrase de
socrate qui apparaissait sur l'écran que
l'erreur est une chance de rebondir le
l'erreur permet d'améliorer les choses
je me suis demandé si c'était toujours
le cas mais je suis souvenu de la limite
de 10 pts vous connaissez le mythe
d'oedipe
lorsqu'il arrive à thèbes il doit
franchir une gorge où se trouve un
animal cruel un sphinx qui pose une
question aux individus en leur demandant
quel est l'animal qui ce matin à quatre
pattes à midi à deux pattes et le soir à
trois pattes
réponse vous la savez depuis le dip
c'est l'homme bref le dit paris lab et
il est confronté à cette question
mais s'il se trompe il est envoyé dans
les décors et disparaît s'ils
réussissent et le sphinx qui tombe qui
libère thème de cette terreur avec toute
la suite d'ailleurs pas très heureuse
pour eux dit mais enfin il devient le
roi de cette ville
c'est donc digital si vous me permettez
l'expression
ou bien en réussi et on est sauvé ou
bien on ne réussit pas et on meurt tous
lui aussi ses contes orientaux dans
lesquels roi se demande à qui va donner
sa fille et lance une enquête dans le
royaume invite les gens qui veulent se
confronter à une question de venir s'il
le trouve la bonne réponse ils ont la
main de la princesse six ans les
mauvaises réponses et bien on leur coupe
la tête et on attend le suivant alors il
ya une part de notre civilisation qui a
peu à la manière de l'esprit du samouraï
dit il faut réussir
ou alors l'échec
ex en mouvement punissable d'un autre
côté l'autre mamelle à pala la tradition
grecque l'autre mamelle de notre culture
c'est évidemment le christianisme qui a
fait jaillir la promotion du pardon et
de la miséricorde encore aujourd'hui ça
se dit assez couramment donc j'ai été
regardée des textes et j'étais surpris
par un certain nombre de choses première
texte que j'ai regardé c'est un texte de
mathieu dans lequel il y à une
discussion entre pierre jésus et pierre
dit combien de fois faut-il pardonner
disent qu'il faut pardonner cette fois
on sait que le chiffre 7 représente dans
la culture hébraïque un chiffre absolu
réponse est non je veux pas pardonner
une fois pas pardonné cette fois il faut
pardonner 70 fois cette fois c'est à
dire pardonner ça mais si on continue à
lire le même texte de ce mathieu on voit
la page suivante à parabole qui est
assez curieuse et qui contredit l'idée
qu'il faut pardonner 70 fois cette fois
c'est la parabole du maître qui n'a pas
suivi les conseils qui viennent de nous
être donnée considère que ce qu'ils lui
doivent l'argent de rendre gorge
il convoque son un débiteur et le
débiteur du doigt une somme considérable
et le débiteur se jette au pied du
maître et puis dimanche en écoute chez
une famille si tu m'oblige à rendre
gorge je vais pas réussir à survivre
alors le maître lui dire bah je te donne
de la monnaie fondante ou bien comment
vous disiez à une dette c'est une dette
fondante bien tâche de me rembourser
quand c'est possible mais vampait est
renoncent à chercher à me rembourser
immédiatement
l'homme sort il voit son propre
débiteurs qui lui doit beaucoup moins il
le saisit à la gorge et lui dit rarement
l'argent sinon je vais te faire envoyer
en prison
alors on se dit où m que son débiteur et
réagit ainsi à l'égard de son propre
débiteur il leur convoque sur les
bitters éluda tu as exagéré tu as pas
fait ce que j'avais fait moi même
alors maintenant tu vas me rendre tout
l'argent et il l'envoie en prison
c'est à dire que le
pardon dans le christianisme c'est
toujours un peu plus compliqué que les
choses simples qui anime maintenant
certain nombre de fanatiques
christianisme il ya toujours de deux
expressions et de vérité qui s'exprime
il dit d'à côté pardonnez 70 x 7 x est
de l'autre côté
oui mais si vous même être pas capable
de pardonner à des tiers alors vous ne
serez pas non plus pardonné
je crois que c'est simplement une leçon
de vie
une société qui n'est pas capable de
donner une deuxième chance à quelqu'un
est bien là de la peine à se développer
à peine à être efficace et à permettre à
chacun de trouver sa place puis comme
j'étais curieux un moment je me suis
référé un autre cas qui est dans la
genèse qui est intéressant aussi c'est
le cas de 15
vous savez que quand tu as belle parce
que il était jaloux de son frère qu'un
était un fermier à leur calme
abel je crois c'est un nomade ou le
contraire enfin il avait des approches
différentes de la vie économique et
qu'un ayant tué son frère se sent tout
d'un coup malheureux de ce qui est
arrivé est l'éternel lui met une marque
est plus qu'un dimanche avec ça je vais
être poursuivi et on va me tuer et
l'éternel lui dit ah non celui qui tuera
qu'un qui est pourtant l'assassin sera
puni cette fois aussi ça veut dire de
manière aiguë à d'autres termes
l'assassin protéger c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire qui
est au fond le fondement d'une
civilisation dans laquelle la vengeance
n'est pas privé la vengeance est public
est celui qui a suivi la vengeance
public doit être protégé faute de quoi
celui qui digère serait une vengeance
privée et condamné poursuivi pour une
très longue période
alors
c'est tout ça c'est des considérations
très élevé il fallait une traduction
politique et institutionnelle de cette
vision du pardon et de la capacité de
faire une erreur morale ou une erreur
tout court et de ce relais ça a été le
travail pendant des siècles de penseurs
et surtout de passeurs de l'époque des
lumières et la premier chapitre auxquels
sont attaqués c'est évidemment le
chapitre pénal puisque le chapitre
pénale est par définition même le
chapitre qui est le plus proche de la
question du délit et des peines pour
reprendre le terme d'un livre qui a été
très célèbre de bekkaria sur les délits
et des peines
c'est le premier qui a dit que les
peines devaient servir à empêcher à
faire peur aux gens qui seraient tentés
de faire la même chose a compensé la le
délit fait et à se corriger dans le
domaine pénal
on a commencé par penser à un certain
nombre de pays
le meilleur moyen de donner une nouvelle
chance à quelqu'un c'est d'éviter la
peine de mort me souviens j'étais enfant
à scat badinter a proposé de supprimer
la peine de mort on était là avec un
groupe d'amis deux cousins du côté de la
famille de ma femme
et parmi nos interlocuteurs il y avait
un militaire un peu bruyant et un peu
simpliste dans ce raisonnement c'est à
dire en avoir la preuve de type a pour
sa part fait des points de vue hamma
camaraderie et de fraternité
puis le coup pris par l'excès il a dit
après tout la peine de mort ça n'a
jamais fait de mal à personne
alors monsieur à le voir quand même du
bon en tous les cas ça évite qui
recommence on lui donne pas de deuxième
chance et vous voyez qu'on était des
gens dans le thème d'aujourd'hui donc la
suppression de la peine de mort c'est la
première fois vous la chute d'une
manière claire de dire chacun doit avoir
une deuxième chance puis il ya tous les
autres nouveaux éléments des codes
pénaux qui sont apparus au cours de sept
ans et par exemple sur 6 qui permet à
quelqu'un de ne pas exécuter sa peine
dans la mesure où il ne revenait pas une
offense contre l'ordre public
il y a aussi la prescription qui est un
petit peu comme la dette qui est évoqué
tout à l'heure chez les juifs y avait ce
qu'on appelle le jubilé sfac tous les to
et 50 ans les dettes étaient annulés
mais comme ce sont des gens pratiquent
en principe les vingt dernières années
avant le jubilé il éviter de prêter trop
pour être pas condamnés à voir
disparaître leur quand même se méfier un
peu des bons sentiments des êtres
humains parfois il y en a qui essaye
quand même de profiter de la situation
avec une certaine habileté
bref la prescription
c'est la décision que après un certain
temps
le délit n'est plus poursuivi
même s'il n'a pas été poursuivie au
auparavant
simplement on estime que si quelqu'un
pendant 20 30 ou 40 ans je suis le délai
de prescription n'a rien fait de
répréhensible
eh bien il a bénéficié d'une seconde
chance de fait et on accepte qu'il ne
sera pas poursuivi
et là il faut constater que notre
société qui par ailleurs essaye d'être
extrêmement libérale parfois même
excessivement libéral l'égard de
certains cas est revenu en arrière
en suisse on a voté l'imprescriptibilité
de certains délits en d'autres termes on
a renoncé à donner une deuxième chance
même avec l'écoulement du temps à
certains délinquants qui avaient commis
des crimes notamment le fameux crimes de
pédophilie avec des conséquences
assez surprenante j'ai pas si vous vous
souvenez il ya quelques années de la
voiture qui était survenu à roman
polanski
lorsqu'il était venu chercher à zurich
un festival de cinéma
un prix qui lui a été attribué par le
festival à sa descente d'avion il n'a
pas été accueilli par comité de
réception du festival mais par deux
policiers qui l'ont emmené parce que
trente ans auparavant il avait commis un
aux états unis un crime contre aux
mineurs et par conséquent il avait
commis le délit de pédophilie qui venait
en suisse d'être considéré comme un
crime imprescriptible à la télévision
ait eu à défendre le point de vue du ou
en en suisse j'ai coûté cher ami peuple
suisse a décidé il ya quinze jours ou
trois semaines je crois que c'était
quelques semaines avant que dorénavant
ce type de crime et est imprescriptible
alors venez pas nous reprocher d'avoir
arrêté polanski quand il venait à
l'invitation des suisses en suisse on a
fait exactement ce que vous voulez et
une des leaders de ce cette action qui
avait abouti à l'initiative m'a écrit
audience est un scandale c'est parce
qu'on voulait c'est parce qu'on veut
faut choisir
toujours est il que dans ce domaine là
donc on est plutôt avec le risque de ne
pas donner une deuxième chance dans
d'autres domaines
la deuxième chance doit exister par
définition c'est dans le domaine de la
science la science par définition c'est
un effort intellectuel pour découvrir la
réalité pour dévoiler la réalité se
basent sur des hypothèses qui sont
contestées et qui peuvent être
contestées et à la fin parfois on
constate qu'elles ne correspondent pas à
la réalité est alors à ce moment-là il y
a une nouvelle hypothèse qui est fait
l'erreur de reconnaissance de l'erreur
le droit à l'erreur est par définition
le moteur de la science est essentielle
et il n'ya pas les hommes
le seul danger c'est que comme la
science est par définition sceptiques
comme on ne connaît pas tous de l'être
humain notamment dit parfois que on
connaît qu environ 10% du fonctionnement
de l'être humain dans l'avion on ne
connaît pas tous certains disent
puisqu'on ne connaît pas tous n'importe
quel prix est aussi vrai que ce qu'on
appelle la médecine scientifique et on
voit fleurir toute une série de théorie
j'avoue jascha léa chemin et il ya un
grand arbre régulièrement je vois des
gens là c'est au tour de l'arbre qui
essayent de communier à la force de la
nature dans un temps il y a dans l'hôtel
d'à côté un groupe qui pratique le cri
primal ou encore la duration du soleil
je rencontre dans la forêt une fois ou
l'autre un charmant qui je suis un
instant et puis quand j'ai compris la
situation je rende pour aller quand même
boire un verre de blanc classique pour
stabiliser
ma vision du monde
donc la deuxième chance il faut pas
qu'elle devienne une chance de faire
n'importe quoi
le problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas
quand on exerce une deuxième chance
quand on est en train de basculer en
politique
la deuxième chance existe dans le
système démocratique vous connaissez ce
qu'on dit de certaines démocraties
africaines ont dit démocratie africaine
un homme une voix une fois s'il n'y a
pas de deuxième chance dans nos systèmes
démocratiques par définition il y à une
deuxième chance deuxième chance on peut
proposer quelque chose si c'était rené
on peut l'enlever on peut soi-même être
candidat à une place et une autre
problème des hommes politiques c'est que
tu as aussi avoir une deuxième chance
mais la deuxième chance c'est quelque
chose d'un peu plus contexte dans ce cas
là et notamment
il faut faire adhésion à la décision qui
ne nous aurait pas convenu en admettant
que c'est les règles du jeu et les gens
acceptent parfois si on n'accepte pas
les règles du jeu c'est on est exclue du
jeu politique
ou alors on ne croit plus du tout ce
qu'ils disent les politiciens c'est ce
qui est arrivé récemment en france
bref je crois que la deuxième chance
mais deuxième chance intelligente et
quelque chose sans laquelle une société
ne peuvent pas survivre à part le fait
que si il n'ya pas deuxième chance ou de
pardon il y a le risque d'une vengeance
continuelle qui met en marche avec la
folie du mimétisme comme on dit la
destruction mutuelle des gens par
vengeance et contre vengeance en pardon
et sans accepter les erreurs
quoique ça c'est un élément mais surtout
nos sociétés ne peuvent progresser que
si elle donne donne une deuxième chance
sans naïveté à tous et qui permettent de
progresser dans la science dans la
politique dans la vie humaine aussi
alors je terminerais je crois que
j'avais une phrase mais je les oublie
entre temps
alors c'est bien qu'il ne l'ait pas misé
on en est toujours aux samouraïs qui est
vraiment redoutable comme les ours qu'on
a vu tout à l'heure à paraître sur la
banquise le il me fait peur ces sociétés
m'inquiète un peu d'ailleurs que
m'inquiète un peu parfois les groupes de
touristes japonais que je vois se
promener honnêtement je n'aurais pas en
faire partie mais et sont des clients en
monnaies fortes on les reçoit bien
volontiers alors ma conclusion finale
c'est le pardon et le droit à l'erreur
c'est comme le poison chez paracelse à
petites doses
ça renforce à grandes doses ça tu vives
le pardon merci
[Applaudissements]